[Music]
it was time for a big change our
integration
architecture couldn't handle the volume
of data exchange that was required
it was absolutely necessary for our
business grow
and to improve customer experience
[Music]
ibm has many years of experience with
running light scale installations
they have a strong link to the open
source community
and brought best practices from easter
project contributors
to ensure we made the right
architectural decisions
[Music]
do
ibm works a lot with enterprise clients
and can deeply understand their
challenges
and this knowledge helps a lot with our
project at burbank
[Music]
so
our mission is to navigate global elite
clients
on their business transformation journey
to make their data accessible
see data in new ways and infuse client
experiences with ai
[Music]
you